they were on sir I took him around yeah
showed them around yeah yeah right now
best friends best friends best friends i
chat or individual maid of honor
oh no it's nice it's cool the thing is
I'm not good at the small talk so I was
I was like guys I'm not the right person
to take them round I'm like hey what do
you have for dinner you know I mean
though I'm not good at that stuff it was
a day Daisy Ridley will never forget I
mean Prince William and Prince Harry
hang with Chewbacca playing with
lightsabers and of course talking to
bb-8 what did they want to know from you
anything no I was just I was just no but
I was also it was nice actually because
I had never done at all before like I'd
never taken anyone round on a tour
before so it's really nice because all
the teams I had met but it's nice sort
of going back a mere like wow instead of
just Keith who is the lightsaber guy on
set you're like oh all of the guys in
the props room who make they're like you
know I mean it's a nice way to remember
all of the people that it takes to make
film I need someone to show me my place
in all this
Luke has always been sort of torn
between the light side dark side there's
sort of traces of this that I don't want
to say do you go to the dark side but do
you flirt with the dark side I think ray
isn't thinking and actually it's
interesting watching it because how I
thought it is and how is you know it's
two slightly different things yes I
don't think ray is thinking about light
side dark side
okay she's thinking Luke is hope right
and kylo is bad because kylo killed her
friend Han and injured her friend Finn
and it's not that it doesn't go deeper
than that for her but on like a on a
more superficial level I don't think
it's so heavy of like oxide light side
it's cheese trying to figure things out
and those questions apply to everything
and I think what's brilliant about this
film is it's less clear what is good and
what is bad people are losing on both
sides people are gaining on both sides
people are dying in wars on both sides
and Adams talked about it to like people
on Star Destroyers have families too so
it is interesting because it and I think
Raiders help serve that as a sort of
tool for the audience because she's
asking questions that go beyond the
black and white and it is all grey
at that before I let you go I carry not
here to celebrate with everybody what
are your feelings today on Karen not
being around watching the film last
night with with everyone was very
emotional and I think it will be her
performance is amazing regardless but I
think it it's a reminder that it's
already tragic thing that
you